determine el seno de 135 grados el cono
de 135 y la tangente de 135 grados
comencemos dibujando un ángulo de 135
grados en posiciones estándar y para
esto permítanme poner aquí un círculo
unitario ok el vértice estará en el
origen del eje y el inicio de este
ángulo estará encima de este eje de las
equis que por cierto me estoy dando
cuenta que no puse la etiqueta de cada
eje este eje horizontal es el eje de las
equis y este eje vertical es el de las
'íes' muy bien entonces tenemos aquí
nuestro lado inicial del ángulo y ya que
es un ángulo positivo s de 135 grados
voy a dibujarlo en sentido antihorario
vamos a ver cuánto necesito recorrer
para llegar a 135 grados si voy de aquí
a acá voy a tener 90 grados que necesito
agregar a 90 grados para llegar a 135
pues 45 grados que es aproximadamente la
mitad
y este otro cuadrante así que mi ángulo
de 135 grados terminará aproximadamente
aquí listo así que este es mi ángulo de
135 grados y lo he dibujado dentro de un
círculo unitario les recuerdo que en un
círculo unitario va a tener un radio de
1 es decir que la distancia del origen a
cualquier punto de la circunferencia va
a valer 1 por lo que aquí en el eje x
este punto es 1 en x aquí en este punto
será también 1 sobre el eje y aquí
tendremos 1 pero como es el lado
negativo del eje x será menos 1 y aquí
vamos a tener también menos 1 pero en el
lado negativo de las 10 sabemos a partir
de la definición como les comentaba de
este círculo que las funciones
trigonométricas el punto de intersección
entre esta circunferencia del círculo
unitario y mi ángulo este punto de
intersección que lo voy a marcar con
otro color para que se note
las coordenadas de este punto me van a
dar las funciones trigonométricas que en
este caso este punto que es sus
coordenadas x como allí
serán igual a el coseno del ángulo en
este caso de 135 grados
el seno de 135 grados las coordenadas de
este punto van a ser el coseno y el seno
de este ángulo así que x va a ser igual
a mi coseno de 135 grados
la coordenada será mi seno de 135 grados
y lo que nos piden también es la
tangente de 135 grados pero yo sé que ye
/ x va a ser igual a la tangente de este
ángulo así pues al encontrar el punto de
intersección encontraremos la respuesta
a este problema y como siempre en este
tipo de problemas para ayudarnos a
resolver esto vamos a dibujar un
triángulo rectángulo y veremos que las
definiciones de las funciones
trigonométricas en el círcol unitario
simplemente son una extensión de soca
todas vamos a dibujar nuestro triángulo
rectángulo dibujando una línea recta a
partir de nuestro punto de intersección
que va a bajar hasta tocar el eje x de
manera perpendicular ahí está
tenemos formado un ángulo de 90 grados
haciendo de esto un triángulo rectángulo
si podemos calcular la base de este
triángulo que voy a remarcar en azul
claro si puedo encontrar la distancia
desde el vértice a este punto de acá
encontraré el valor de x de la
coordenada x y si yo encuentro el valor
de la distancia en este lado vertical
esta será la distancia o la longitud de
la coordenada ya que esto es el valor de
este punto con respecto al eje y
pensemos en lo que sabemos de este
triángulo de aquí son fabulosos los
triángulos rectángulos mi primera
pregunta para ustedes es cuánto mide la
hipotenusa de este triángulo y si
recuerdan les acabo de mencionar está
dentro de un círculo unitario
esto va del vértice a un punto de la
circunferencia por lo tanto va a medir 1
este es un radio mide 1 la hipotenusa de
este triángulo mi segunda pregunta para
ustedes es pueden encontrar los ángulos
dentro de este triángulo en particular
el ángulo de referencia que es el que se
encuentra a partir de éste terminador y
el eje x
este ángulo que estoy marcando aquí lo
pueden encontrar yo creo que sí pues
este ángulo es suplementario a este
ángulo de 135 grados sabemos que de esta
parte del eje a esta otra parte son 180
grados nuestro ángulo mide 135 cuánto le
falta para llegar a 180 grados pues le
faltaría agregar 45 grados para llegar a
esta media vuelta o este medio círculo
entonces nuestro ángulo suplementario o
el ángulo de referencia es de 45 grados
y también sabemos que la suma de los
ángulos internos de un triángulo siempre
nos debe dar 180 grados
este es un triángulo rectángulo este es
un ángulo de 90 grados 90 + 45 nos va a
dar 135 cuánto nos falta para completar
180 muy bien nos faltan otros 45 grados
por lo tanto este ángulo de aquí arriba
va a ser 45 grados también y para seguir
analizando este triángulo voy a
dibujarlo un poquito más grande
aquí a un lado tengo
este lado
tengo este otro lado que está en azul
más claro más o menos así
tengo lo que marca el terminador de mi
ángulo de 135
voy a marcar los demás ángulos
este que damos que es de 45 grados
este de aquí también es de 45 grados
y este es mi ángulo recto por lo que es
90 grados 90 grados y marcamos que la
hipotenusa vale 1
la siguiente pregunta es podemos
calcular los lados que nos faltan de
este triángulo pensemos un momento en
ello nos damos cuenta de que este
triángulo tiene dos ángulos iguales por
lo que estos dos lados van a ser iguales
también más adelante veremos que los
triángulos de 45 45 90 son buenos
triángulos para aprendernos las
proporciones de los lados iguales con
respecto a la hipotenusa usando el
teorema de pitágoras estos lados son
iguales voy a ponerles una letra para
marcar la longitud que tendrán vamos a
ponerle a
aplicando el teorema de pitágoras que
vamos a obtener pues la suma del
cuadrado de los lados debe ser igual al
cuadrado de la hipotenusa por lo tanto a
de un lado al cuadrado que es la
longitud de lo que es un lado más la
longitud del otro lado que es la misma
que el primer lado al cuadrado debe ser
igual a la hipotenusa al cual que es 1
al cuadrado 1 al cuadrado viene siendo 1
tenemos entonces que esto es igual a 2
al cuadrado igual a 1
despejamos la que es la que me interesa
el lado al cuadrado es igual a un medio
ya que dividimos ambos lados entre 2
voy a tener a es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de un medio que es igual a 1 /
raíz cuadrada de 2 y si quieren
racionalizar lo lo vamos a multiplicar
todo por raíz de 2 / raíz de 2 que es lo
mismo que multiplicarlo por 1 raíz de 2
/ raíz de 2 me va a quedar raíz cuadrada
de 2 / raíz cuadrada de los x raíz
cuadrada de 2 me va a quedar igual a 2 a
el lado va a ser igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 2 entre 2 cada uno de estos
valores igual a raíz cuadrada de 2 entre
2 y esto también raíz cuadrada de 2
entre 2 esto es de este triángulo aquí
solito ahora este triángulo regresando a
su posición en el círculo unitario vemos
que esta x realmente se encuentra en el
lado negativo del eje x por lo que va a
ser un valor negativo esta x va a ser
igual a menos raíz de 2 entre 2
pues se encuentra en el lado positivo y
si no tenemos problemas la aie va a
valer
raíz cuadrada de 2 entre 2 este lado así
pues mi coordenada de este punto de
intersección cuál va a ser pues tenemos
la coordenada x menos raíz de 2 entre 2
y mi coordenada en ya que es raíz de 2
entre 2 y ya habíamos visto que estos es
lo mismo que el coste no de 135 grados y
esto es lo mismo que el seno de 135
grados así que puedo responder a mi
pregunta x igual al costo de 135 grados
es igual a menos raíz de 2 entre 2 y c
935 grados es igual a raíz de 2 positivo
entre 2
/ x que es la tangente de 135 grados
esta va a ser igual y es raíz de 2 entre
/ x que es menos menos
a raíz de dos entre dos estos dos se
cancelan y me va a quedar un número
negativo entre x la tangente de 135
grados finalmente me queda que es igual
a menos 1